uh the midterm election season for 2022
is likely to start earlier than ever
this time around I was talking to our
YouTube rep recently and he said expect
interest in these 2022 midterms to start
and to see more serious campaigning and
interest on YouTube as early as spring
of next year rather than more like early
summer and there are some really good
reasons why we would expect that not
only are there increasingly interesting
particular races to look at including
the Texas gubernatorial election where
Beto O'Rourke is running Pennsylvania
Senate we now have this quack cure
promoter Dr Mehmet Oz we also have John
fetterman running on the Democratic side
okay that's interesting so we've got
interesting races starting to fill the
docket but the stakes are extremely high
in terms of who controls the House and
Senate starting in January of 2023 and
we can go through a long list of reasons
that this is important including to what
degree Republicans will be able to
Stonewall anything Joe Biden tries to do
they've been partially stonewalling
everything so far they might completely
Stonewall everything if they take
control of the house but maybe just as
importantly is the reality that the
current Republican party is wackier than
it has ever been
and among their goals is this simmering
idea of making Donald Trump speaker of
the house if they take control of the
House of Representatives in November now
you might be saying whoa whoa stop the
clock David Trump isn't running for
house how could it be the speaker you
may or may not know one does not have to
be a member of the House of
Representatives to be speaker of the
house where I'll talk to rokana about
this when we have him back on the show
soon the house can vote for anybody if
the house decides they want me to be
speaker of the house I could be speaker
of the house and starting months ago
there was this idea which was mentioned
on Steve bannon's bizarre program of
installing Donald Trump as Speaker of
the House even without him being a
member of the House of Representatives
impeaching Joe Biden and then having
Donald Trump preside over the vote to
impeach Joe Biden in the house
beleaguered radical republican
Congressman Matt Gates is is really into
this idea
starting back in July he started talking
about if we win in 22 we will make
Donald Trump speaker of the house and at
the time it seemed that it might have
just been a publicity ploy to fundraise
get attention maybe raise money for his
legal defense fund but Matt Gates
mentioned it again in August and he
mentioned it again yesterday senior
White House correspondent for Yahoo news
Alexander nazarian published a tweet
about this saying quote Matt Gates just
told me at a press conference that if
Republicans win the house in 22 he will
move to install Trump as house speaker
so there are really three questions here
question one is Matt Gates serious he
appears to be second question would
Republicans actually nominate Trump to
be speaker of the house if they took
control and the third question is if
nominated would Republicans overall
actually vote to make Donald Trump
Speaker of the House the answers to the
first two questions are pretty simple
Matt Gates is serious
and I do think that Donald Trump would
be nominated for speaker of the house if
Republicans take control in 2022 the
third question is the key question
just because Republicans take control
and someone nominates Trump to be
speaker do they really elect Trump to be
Speaker of the House understand that
it's an open question not morally but
strategically if Trump is don't do
particularly well in the November
midterms if Donald Trump's power within
the party seems diminished it's less
likely that Republicans would be willing
to do something so cartoonish on the
other hand and particularly if
Republicans take control of the house on
the basis of many trumpists winning new
seats in the house it is completely
plausible that Republicans would be
willing to make Trump speaker of the
house and it would be one of the most
cartoonish and pathetic circumstances in
American politics in a very very long
time unfortunately the combination of
historical Trends where the first
midterm after a new president is usually
bad for that party meaning it would be
bad for Democrats in November come
combined with gerrymandering
combined with population shifts that
might see Democrats losing a few seats
just on that basis it is looking more
and more like Republicans are going to
win the house in November it's not a
guarantee and when I say that I'm not
saying it so that we do nothing
I'm saying it so that we don't throw in
the towel and we actually fight for the
house because if we lose that house
it's going to be very very bad for a
long period of time